things about life-threatening situations
such as flooding and also wild fires
well joining me now is the security and
intelligence expert Professor Anthony
glees good to have you on the program
particularly for this historic moment
and that we understand that if it goes
to plan every 4G and 5G device in the
country should omit this 10 second
warning sound are you confident it'll
work
well it it didn't work properly in
Florida the company everbridge that is
also Supply this signal got its contract
removed just two days ago it's a very
big blow scared everybody witness in
Florida when it went off at four o'clock
in the morning so I think the
government's got to be fairly confident
that it does go and I confident too that
it doesn't terrify us so it's quite an
exciting moment the government is
connecting directly through the mobile
phone Mass with each and every one of us
who has a smartphone of one kind or
another it's a big day in that sense
yeah we're talking about millions of
phones aren't we right across the
country I mean how complicated is it
sending a signal to every smartphone in
the UK
well I'm not techy but it clearly very
complicated as we saw in the case of
Florida and not just Florida this has
often gone wrong so a signal has been
sent where no signal should go we're now
going to see if when a signal is meant
to go out it does actually go out but
that's just the most kind of superficial
aspect of what will be a hugely
expensive experiment I mean last year
everbridge the American company that's
selling this software all around the
world not just for the UK or United
States they made profits in excess of
400 million dollars and a 17 increase in
what they're getting so we're talking
really big amounts of British taxpayers
money for this um gig and it may not be
to everybody's liking I believe in good
security and I believe in warning people
in a timely and appropriate way wherever
possible but this kind of stuff I think
definitely goes too far
oh well there you go that's that's
certainly our runner's phone which we've
put on the desk here right in front of
me and I'm sure you can hear that as
well so we have a quick listen in let's
have a listen
okay
well early we should first first uh
first time we could say that about
anything in this country yeah we're not
talking about the trains are we um I
think we've got 30 seconds to go before
three o'clock it was actually too early
to tell you did yours go off at the same
time as well did yours go off it might
went off at the same time but it's not
uh three o'clock yet it's a minute early
and that will be disquieting for some
people did not go off exactly when it
was meant to go off
right okay well it's now three o'clock
let's see if we get another signal we
probably won't will we I mean it was
loud wasn't it and it was so it must be
10 seconds that seemed like a very short
10 seconds for me actually I can hear
other people's phones going off in the
gallery behind me here so it looks like
it's it's been staged were you expecting
that or were you is it a case that some
phones are going to get the signal just
a few seconds early
well I I won't expect it because it's
never been done before but we've had
checks during the covid crisis and very
useful they've been to at the time of
major national emergency but we've never
had anything like this and as I said
before it's very hard to know exactly
what people want you to do in a real
emergency when you get this the text may
say in your region there's a fire in the
region of terrorism in your region
there's a flood but then what you know
do you kiss your backside goodbye do you
run into a seller if you're lucky enough
to have one do you go into the street
the danger that this sort of thing can
cause Panic is probably as great as
trying to keep people from getting into
a dangerous situation you know I
understand they have it in America it
doesn't work very well there and I
understand that it's an I.T Gizmo that
uh you you can sell to people and make a
lot of money but just because you can do
it doesn't mean you should do it and it
puts the government in direct contact
with each and every smartphone use that
the government said they're not going to
gather data from us they're not going to
misuse this in any way but you know it
is a step up towards the Big Brother
surveillance State and I believe in
using mining mobile phone information to
keep the people in this country safe and
the very special conditions but
generally giving the government a chance
to call each and every one of us up and
Nanny state does not begin to do it yeah
you certainly sound skeptical I'm just
going to read out the uh the little
notices that's come with it with a phone
that I've got in front of me here it
says there's a test of emergency alerts
and a new UK government service that
will warn you if there's a
life-threatening emergency nearby in a
real emergency follow the instructions
in the alert to keep yourself and others
safe visit gov dot UK forward slash
alerts for more information this is a
test you do not need to take any action
um but the question that you raise is in
a real life situation if there was a
real emergency would people understand
the the information being given to them
and the instructions being followed I
mean Oliver Dowden was on the on Sky new
Zeal earlier of course he's a new Deputy
Prime Minister saying this this could
save people's lives so maybe it's better
to have a belt and braces approach here
well I don't I should never say no but I
don't see precisely how it can save
people's lives unless it is very very
tightly focused on a specific area I
mean in Canary wildfires or floods you
know we see some devastating floods in
this country recently you know flash
flooding happens very quickly you could
Target this to to an area of the country
where they're at risk of flash flooding
and indeed people being people drowning
well I know that in theory you could do
it and the techie people who sold this
to Oliver Dowding and other governments
been going on for more than 10 years
it's not just this government that's
that's bought the idea they're obviously
being told oh you'll save lives and as I
say if you're all Canary War for in the
Palace of Westminster this kind of alert
could indeed be useful but I don't see
how you could make it that specific and
and more generally you could face all
kinds of situations where the ordinary
punter really would know would not know
what to do and panic in many cases Panic
is more dangerous than anything else so
I I do feel this is a step too far and I
do feel particularly elderly people may
be distressed and alarmed by it and I
think government should beware their
track record with I.T is appalling
people who remember you know who said
they weren't going to be brexit prom
because the borders were going to be all
smart technology it was all going to be
done with tracking Etc governments
aren't good at this they get sold stuff
and it doesn't work so good security
absolutely alerting people absolutely
particularly at times of Crisis
absolutely but in everybody's home
I don't think so not in this way
okay we'll leave it there Professor
Anthony gleas thank you so much for your
time
um let's talk to uh Tom Cheto our
correspondent who's they're joining us
in West London we've had as you've had
cameras up and down the country haven't
we Tom um in West London March reaction
did you hear it
yeah I mean it was a bit of a cacophony
wasn't it a bit of a surprise because it
did come early so people here looking at
their phones ask everyone they're
finishing their Sunday lunch is what
they thought of it guys when that alarm
went off were you expecting it was that
how you think it was going to be
it didn't go off your thing go off yes
you didn't get one no I came later some
of us came before us so uh yeah and was
it loud was it quieter than it was it
not loud enough for an emergency in that
situation maybe next time they can do it
come over here guys um was it as you
expected did you know it's going to
happen
um I knew it was gonna happen but it
actually didn't endorses
so around this table some have been
selected some have been left behind as
they were yeah and did you know I mean
there was some sort of briefing around
it because it's the first time it's been
used did you all know it was going to
happen is it something that the message
you got through
I have heard about it but through people
at work not through any sort of
notifications I thought the wording was
a bit extreme I had more sense well I
think severe alert when it's a test is a
little bit far yeah but not not too much
of an interruption to a Sunday afternoon
a good way good way to finish a good
lunch by the notes and things thanks
very much guys so yeah a bit of a mixed
reaction lots of people not getting into
that and that's interesting because when
you think about what this is everyone in
the country where 88 of people has a
smartphone so there's never really been
so many people in the UK looking at the
same thing at the same time that's if
everyone got that message of course have
you been talking about the government
says that is important for safety in
terms of warning of a terrorist threat
it can be more geographically located
others pointing out there's probably
Fizz around privacy but it's got a very
mixed reaction here in Southwest London
okay for now Tom thank you very much Tom
Tasha they're joining us live from South
West London
and that was uh the alert that you
should have got just a few minutes ago
reminding you of a uh of an alert but it
being just an alarm at this particular
occasion for you to swipe left but
listen for the future